hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong for a super
scintillating sensational edition of the
show here i am merely mark ellis joined
as always by my illustrious co-host
jacqueline coley who jaclyn we have
breaking news here on the show as it
pertains to your life you recently found
a gift card for the outback steakhouse
worth a hundred dollars now
here's the question i have for you isn't
there some law that was recently passed
that like any gift card ever is now
valid and there's no expiration date
this is true but it's not retroactive
and california was actually one of these
places at four is because it used to be
with gift cards that they actually
wanted you to i think it's still the
case they want you to forget about them
so that that's how they make their money
off of gift cards like that's the whole
point of gift cards is that hope that
you lose it because they have this thing
where they can like deduct money from it
every year that it stays in use a
servicing fee and so it eventually goes
to zero so i'm pretty sure that outback
yeah i'm pretty sure that outback
steakhouse was already zero when that
rule came into effect plus since i got
it like as i was saying for my high
school graduation
which was a couple if i wanted to go to
outback i could
okay well look if you want to take me to
black angus instead i've never been
there so i'm pretty
amenable to whatever steakhouse you
prefer i'll go fancy i'll do a morton's
i can put on a dinner jacket for that
and the reason why i bring up the
outback or really any steak restaurant
is that where do steaks come from a lot
of them come from the midwest and our
story of the movie today takes place in
kansas but it's kansas by way of krypton
the planet that maybe it's too soon it
ain't there anymore sorry it's it pulled
an alder on and exploded but before
krypton exploded we got this man of
steel guy that escaped as a baby and
that's the movie we're talking about man
of steel the movie that sort of kicked
off the dc eu for better for worse
directed by zack snyder produced by some
guy who knows his way around a superhero
flick named christopher nolan and
jacqueline you know everybody is is
slurping the batman these days and
people are so excited about that
character but there's always been this
chatter of like when are we gonna get
another man of steel movie dc seems to
have some good things going for it in
2022 so while we wait on official word
of that in the meantime we do get to
relive a movie that
you know
it seemed like it was more divisive than
it had to be at the time and so we put
fresh eyes on it almost 10 years later
did you feel exactly the same as you
always had watching this movie
absolutely i'm sorry
you don't have to apologize
i feel so bad because i know how much
people love this i know i've given the
dc a bad rap but i went back and
actually looked i've had more fun with
dc movies than not
i will say this but this is not that
movie okay well there's a lot of fans
that i would imagine disagree with you
they wanted us to talk about this one
way or the other and a few of those
illustrious names are dave horseman
stephen gilbeau
johann gustafsson
jacob schroeder
maybe schroeder like the quarterback and
landon brown and landon actually wrote i
thoroughly believe the rotten tomatoes
got it wrong with man of steel zack
snyder's more grounded take on superman
is what we needed this more coming of
age like superman shows what it would be
like if the man of steel actually lives
on our earth and does a fantastic job
with it it also dives in on the morale
dilemma of one life versus many lives
and that being a superhero is not black
and white sincerely a dc fan that is
landon and landon thinks that the tomato
meter is wrong currently 56
rotten so it's oh so close to fresh it's
fresh adjacent but man of steel is still
rotten on the tomato meter however its
audience score is a fresh 75
and so with that we welcome in our
esteemed guest today who knows no
introduction either on our show or at a
local outback steakhouse he's a host
critic writer and the chief executive
officer of the outlaw nation outlet he
hosts some of the some of the many of
the podcasts that he hosts you got the
geek buddies cinephiles the top ten
covering the worlds of film tv and
entertainment and he's also a pretty big
sports honk john rocca the outlaw is
here with us john it is a pleasure to
have you back on the show um
you and i are commanders
and well we're for yourself but yes go
ahead
you are a commander it's our favorite
football team regardless of how we feel
about the name of the owner or the
current quarterback let's see if we can
at least align forces here with man of
steel i ask you the question first is
rotten tomatoes wrong about man of steel
with that 56 percent rotten tomato meter
score well first thanks to you and
jackie for having me back on i always
have a good time here and i'm excited to
be back into a battle for the man of
steel and absolutely ron tomatoes is
wrong 56 is an abhorrent score for such
an incredible film that i dare say
is more topical now considering all
we've seen in our world that everything
is happening in our world over the last
few years than it was even back then and
it was it was so i would argue it's
ahead of its time and people need to go
back and re-watch this movie and
re-appreciate some of the things that
zack snyder was trying to tell us about
our world and tell us about the
experience of being an alien on this
planet all right so how high up are you
getting this movie are you getting this
movie to like a territory is it a b plus
well for me it's absolutely in the b
plus a minus territory absolutely
absolutely all right jacqueline you now
have the four rotten tomatoes feels like
you agree with them no they're wrong it
should be lower it should be so much
slower wow this is it's humorless and
drab and i was excited when that planet
blew up because i didn't want to be
anywhere near it with their baby
incubator pod it was just it's just so
not the t
compared to like and i get it totally
different thing you can't do the same
thing but compared to the hope that was
inspired from the donner superman's to
the gloom as we literally and my dog
chimes in
mourn
the superman mythology throughout this
movie i i just it's almost as if i feel
like zack snyder has never seen
a rain-drenched superhero that he didn't
want to frame in some kind of melancholy
you know what i mean i'm like i'm like
can we just the man that flies through
like to buildings like why does it have
to be such a downer and i say that as
someone that watches downer movies all
the time but maybe just not this
yeah not about it it's not a wonder that
the man's first movie was about a bunch
of people being murked well i mean it
sounds like jaclyn's dog agrees more
with john roca because your dog had some
strong feelings about that i will say
this hearing jaclyn's description of man
of steel if you didn't say the title of
the movie i would have guessed you're
talking about the most recent the batman
but we tend to like the darkness we tend
to like the grittiness when it comes to
gotham city but with superman since 1978
we've been sort of trained to look at
that as hope and optimistic and yay the
best things of humanity and
extraterrestrials so i am going to have
the sculding hot take of saying that
rotten tomatoes is dead on 56 is exactly
where this movie belongs uh john i don't
mind getting it up to fresh if if we
really need to but i can't put it past
the mid 60s jaclyn i have no problem
saying that it's close to fresh but it's
not quite fresh for me
but we're going to get into all of that
we're going to get into the discussion
it seems like i'm going to be moderating
i'm going to be the uh the gym layer of
this presidential debate but before we
get to all of that we turn it over to
our dear friend tim ryan he's our expert
review curation manager here at rotten
tomatoes and he's going to tell us what
the critics were saying at the time of
man of steel's release way back when we
were so young in 2013 it's two minutes
with tim time
[Music]
can there be a gritty reboot of superman
more to the point is it lightness
optimism and good humor that makes
superman who he is it's a question that
critics considered while watching man of
steel which many felt had undeniably
exciting action scenes but too often
succumbed to ponderousness man of steel
is rotten at 56 with 340 reviews but it
does have a 75 audience score so what
did the critics have to say in a rotten
review chris wagner of the dallas
morning news wrote the movie can't
decide if it wants to be a particularly
thoughtful brand of superhero saga or a
definitely generic summer action movie
so it ends up being both to the
detriment of it and us however in a
fresh review charlie mccollum of the san
jose mercury news wrote the result is a
film that while relentlessly grim and
badly in need of humor manages to be a
smart nuanced take on the superman
mythology the rotten tomatoes critics
consensus reads man of steel's
exhilarating action and spectacle can't
fully overcome its detours into generic
blockbuster territory so that's man of
steel let's kick it back to jacqueline
and mark who i have every reason to
believe are big fans of truth justice
and the american way back to you folks
yeah there was a whole lot of people
saying a whole lot of stuff about man of
steel then and now because it was a
financially successful still haven't
gotten a sequel to it we kind of got
sort of more superman with the b versus
s and then with the justice leagues but
a lot of folks waiting for that proper
man of steel sequel so we'll talk about
that but before we get into speculating
about the future let's dive deep into
man of steel warnings spoilers of plenty
coming up as usual on this show let's
hit the movie talk music
[Music]
all right john well we should probably
start with this let's just take a wide
view of the entire superman lineage
starting with i mean we can go back to
steve reeves if you want to but i'm
looking at christopher reeve i'm going
to give a shout out to brandon rowell
thought he was a fine superman maybe not
the best movie but i liked him and then
we have henry cavill is henry cavill
john rocca's favorite superman yes bar
none bar none absolutely he's the most
representative of what superman actually
is and for people who only grew up on
the donner superman and never went
backwards to study the history of
superman he is the most representative
of what superman was and did and his
progress and his journey and remember
you know i hear jackie's point i think
jackie's point's a valid point a lot of
people love those richard donner
superman certainly i love the rich i
just bought them in 4k they're fantastic
they're inspirational they're hopeful
three and four the less said about them
the better but you have to remember the
time when that was coming out we are
coming out of vietnam it's about 1978.
star wars as well is around the same
time it's about hope it's about getting
people to believe in humanity again
getting to believe that we can be good
again we want to overcome this stuff
right before we get into the me
generation of the 80s this superman
henry cavill this is the more accurate
representation of who we are as a
society now all of us deal with the
darkness all of us deal with feeling
excluded all of us deal with trying to
discover our own path our own way to the
light and i would say it's one of the
most uplifting films about superman one
of the most inspirational films and
realistic films about finding your way
to an inspirational place in your life
and so that's why i think cavill does
his his acting his performance his
moments with uh amy adams his moments
with his with his dad especially with
kevin costner my god there's some
beautiful moments there and his moments
with his mom later on with diane diane
lane doing incredible work there as well
there's so much to savor and enjoy from
henry cavill's performance and
christopher reeve a decent actor but i
think cabell's a bit more um
how can i say this a bit more he's got a
bit more rage so a decent actor the guy
went to juilliard he hung out with
robert williams for crying out loud um
you know jacqueline it is interesting to
think about like the product of the
times but then i also look at superman
as a character who elevates above that
and will take if we're going through a
grunge here we're going through a
war-torn era we're coming out of a
some decade where it was all about
selfishness and greed don't you i feel
like superman is like no this is what i
represent and i'm going to make you
folks come to me i'm not coming down to
your level and dealing with whatever
crap you just went through for the last
10 years it's a it's a mix of both but i
think that a lot of folks were maybe
left cold by henry cavill's superman
just because they look to the most
optimistic of the superheroes like a
christopher reeves superman so i'm
guessing you're a christopher reeve gal
yeah i'm a christopher reeve guy but
honestly i'm really a george reeves guy
being completely honest like it was
funny the only reason why i blocked it
what
uh john said about henry cavill is not
because that i actually like henry
cavill as superman i think he embodies
the physicality-ness of it the sort of
boyish
charm of it it's also the reason why i
think andrew garfield was a great
spider-man because that sort of like
quippy but thoughtful thing is part of
who he is and so it radiates through the
character but actually yeah george
reeves who actually hated playing
superman
like you know if you want to watch
hollywoodland he really sort of despised
it because it really was just a
children's show at that time
but he you know when i think of superman
i still think of that sort of like you
know underwear over the tights superman
and he embodies that for me my big
problem with man of steel actually has
very little to do with henry cavill and
much more to do with
himself i'm not saying his name because
the internet will find me um
yeah i just it's there's incredible
moments you write with diane uh laid and
incredible moments with kevin costner
that bus scene you know the the him
dying scene is absolutely moving and
gripping his stuff with lois is also
the only i feel like tongue-in-cheek
aspect of the movie happens between her
and cavill as they play their sort of
like well what do you think you are and
who do you think you are and all of
those
sort of other aspects and elements
but it's just joyless
he should be saving the world and
there's no joy in that prospect i think
that we i think we're all in the same
i'm a christopher reeve guy for the
record i think capital is great though i
think we can all agree that that he is
not responsible for any of the faults
that we might find with man of steel the
the thing that we all can find common
ground on here is that as the movie
starts out we do get this exciting
sequence on krypton where it's lateral i
mean
you talk about getting out in the nick
of time russell crowe is jorel he knows
that his planet is doomed he's
challenging zod who's taking control of
the entire planet and they just kind of
like did what we are doing very slowly
on earth they did it very quickly where
just you just kind of harvest all the
resources then kaboom but we get cowell
out in time and so he's on this ship and
he lands on earth once he's in kansas i
think those are the strongest scenes in
in the movie because kevin costner and
diane land are just such powerful
parents who just have that midwestern
tough farmer
work ethic discipline but they're also
compassionate they also found this thing
and they feel like this thing was put in
their lives for a reason the pah kent
stuff interacting with his kid
i mean it can almost bring you to tears
on the level of a field of dreams
another great midwestern corn movie
starring kevin coster and so those are
really the highlights for me john where
i feel like this smoothie left me cold
and why i'm okay with it staying rotten
is that i never felt like it shifted
into third gear i thought the action
scenes while it's thrilling to look at
how realistic we've come we've come for
flying technology and like making these
scenes feel like they're actually
happening they felt very repetitive and
boring it was superman getting angry
flying fast into somebody and i just
felt like we kept seeing that through
the rest of the movie am i am i way off
base here well you know when you go back
to the first year of the schmoe's no
mark ellis is not who you see now mark
ellis is a very you know professional
polished host now but if you go back to
those first years of of mark ellis they
weren't that great he was doing the same
thing over and over again repeating some
of the stuff this is what you see this
is a superman who is still in the first
fight of his entire life and it's
against a fellow kryptonian so he's
gonna be messy he's gonna you know be uh
inexperienced he's gonna keep repeating
the same things uh like you do when you
play a video game sometimes you keep oh
i found a move that works i'm just keep
using that move until they counter it
that's how he's doing he's figuring it
out on the fly you know and i saw some
of these same criticisms with the batman
recently it's year two how good were you
on your second year at the job it's not
an easy job to be a superhero there's a
lot of things that are involved in it
and he's fighting a guy who is more
seasoned more mil he's got better
military tactics more experienced all
these kinds of things so he is having to
necessarily he's having to kind of rely
on the fl do trouble shooting fighting
at the same time so you are going to see
some things that are repetitive but that
moment when he walks out of the forces
of solitude that cape is billowing and
that lights behind him and that hans
zimmer's score hits and he you hear uh
uh jarrell's voices in his voice in his
ear and he flies for the first time it's
amazing and there's a tongue-in-cheek
moment because he hits the thing because
he can't quite fly yet he has to figure
it out so i think there's so much here
that you have to put in context this is
a new superman his first time dawning
the cape doing all the things that he's
doing so if you can put that in context
you can understand why he is a bit
repetitive or makes some mistakes or it
seems a bit like it's
you're seeing the same thing over and
over again and i think it actually kind
of works and helps you to connect with
the character more because all of us
have tried to do something that we're
eventually good at we just had to
stumble through the first few times of
doing it until we figured it out that's
an excellent point that rook is making
here jacqueline i guess my counter to it
would be that i also never felt while
watching this person find their footing
like bambi on walking on the ice for the
first time you also it's the first time
in history superman's been compared to
bambi you also
never at least for me my emotions were
never moved as much as they were when
he's interacting with his adopted
parents on earth it just i think
emotionally the rest of the movie just
felt a little stifled to me did you pick
up on any of that yeah i did i also
picked up on the subtle amount of shade
that john gave you during his breakdown
and i don't want to like
push over that because that is showdown
ladies and gentlemen they will make
their point but find a way to like i
don't know embody their heel status john
that's
chef kisser
john is one of the best we've ever had
in that
exactly yeah i mean look the idling and
gear thing
that you talk about um the only thing
that i can think of in pop culture that
similarly reminds me of this phenomenon
is every song by the mumford and sons
every song by the mumford and sons feels
like a preamble to a better song they
did it right
everything about
man of steel
is like a preamble to like and then when
we finally get to going you know when
they're finally getting it
it feels so to jon's point to your point
haphazard and messy and not even the
like it's sort of like even if you hated
the last jedi when rey
and emo kylo turn backs and they're like
going at it we are all there because
they geared up to a moment that we could
all get behind
and they just don't do that in this
movie and that is a problem for a movie
where you're supposed to be
the the idea of a superhero is this
global idea of someone you have to root
for because they're saving the world
right they're saving the world you have
to root for them zack snyder pulled the
greatest magic trick in the world
because he had somebody save the world
where we have no choice but to look at
him like why
why did you do it like that and that is
not a good way to be and then he made an
entire sequel dissecting this weird
taste that he left in everyone's mouth
yeah i i won't disagree with jackie on
the sequel i did not i'm not a bvs
person whether ultimate cut or regular
cut i am not a bbs you're not yeah this
movie but i love this movie yeah
and i don't hate this movie it's just
not a good one it's just not a good one
i i'm finding myself right in between
y'all again because i'm not the biggest
batman versus superman defender we had a
great chat with mike kalinowski about it
i think last year but what i loved about
beaver success and my favorite sequence
possibly in batman vs superman is when
we get the fight
that is superman and zod the climax of
man of steel but we get to see it from
the perspective of the boots on the
ground
bruce wayne and he's running towards
dangers everybody else is running away
from it that was the most thrilling
sequence of batman v superman which is
interesting because i felt like that
whole thing just again left me out in
the cold a little bit but there was a
moment if you want to talk about
the last jedi with them going back to
back and taking on a bunch of praetorian
guards it's a great moment there's a
moment that i think was a risk and i
like that they took the risk i'm just
wondering how we feel about it almost a
decade later john and i think you know
what i'm getting to this is a superman
that will snap a neck if needed and so
he finds himself in the impossible
position of either having to go against
what his like you said brand new i guess
vow is that he's not going to kill
anyone but zod is threatening the entire
world so maybe one next snapped isn't
all that bad i had no problem with it
because the movie did set up what those
stakes are your take on it then and now
yeah i loved it i thought it was gutsy i
thought it was something we obviously
something we had not seen on screen
before from superman i thought it was
realistic for what's going on in our
world and how we deal with tyrants or
wannabe tyrants how we deal with these
people who have no value for human life
and are willing to risk any human life
to achieve their idea of ethnic
superiority that's was in essence who
zod represents he's essentially a
supremacist pick your race he's
essentially a supremacist who believes
that crypto kryptonia isn't only the
high-end kryptonians are allowed to live
remember that jorel says to him who's
going to pick the bloodline that lives
in your in your scenario do you get to
pick him and he's a general who's a
military guy so in his eyes it's even
worse than the bloodlines that he wants
to pick to survive it would turn them
into a militaristic people that's what
he wants here so with with the situation
when he's coming down to this battle and
he's look he's he's overmatched he's
inexperienced and remember he just
finished like fighting off the world
engine so he's supremely exhausted and
now he's fighting a guy who's fresh
who's taken up taking him to task and
he's in this moment and he makes a very
powerful decision
to kill zod to snap his neck because
he's gonna kill that family and zod has
said over and over again i'm going to
kill everybody on this planet the world
engine was essentially terraforming the
planet so everybody dies so he can put
he can put essentially a new krypton on
earth
populated by the people he believes
should be populated so there is so much
happening here in context that when he
makes this decision it's not a decision
he takes he does lightly and when he
kills him he is he's in essence killing
the last connection to krypton that he
has the last connection to his father
because uh azad knew his father it's
there's so much weight here remember the
codex is still in him so essentially for
the kryptonians he's killing him and in
that moment he releases the scream and
it's the scream of the death of jorel
the death of his dad of kevin costner's
father of jonathan ken and the death
here of his last connection to his
planet
[Music]
[Applause]
and so there's so much weight here so i
think there's it's it's so well built to
this moment and by the way for you
superman you know uh hardcore people
jerry siegel and joe schuster had
superman kill back in the 30s 40s and
50s he only stopped killing in the 60s
and 70s or what was going on in the
world in the 60s and 70s and then and
then throughout and then then in the 80s
and 90s he's killed as well doomsday the
death of superman he kills doomsday so
this idea of self-defense killing this
is what this is that's what he does in
this moment so i've always been like
blown away by the people who have no
knowledge of the superman history that
it's not something that's been there
since the beginning that he doesn't kill
he kills in certain situations for
self-defense or for a bigger reason he
has done so in the comics this was just
the first time he saw him do it on
screen and i thought it was handled
incredibly well by zack snyder and by
david goyer who wrote the script and i
could i could point to many instances in
batman films where it's like if you
would just kill this guy things would be
a lot easier for us and so i'm all for
superheroes killing certainly
i look at superheroes killing especially
like the more noble ones like we know
what punisher is about but if you're
talking about batman or superman i think
them killing is kind of like me eating a
hot dog after i go to the gym is it the
most ideal protein no
is it what i want to have no but
occasionally if that's all you can grab
before you go to your next assignment i
gotta get the protein somehow i'm going
to eat a hot dog that was seeing
superman eat a hot dog jaclyn when you
see that moment does that make the movie
better or worse in your eyes or did were
you just checked out by that point that
zod's neck got checked out ding ding
ding i have to be really clear about
this movie
i went back to re-watch it
twice this time it took me four times
the first time to watch it because it's
so interesting that you guys i don't
know which one of you said i think it
was maybe mark maybe john that opening
thrilling moment in krypton yeah what
movie were y'all watching i love that
that point was boring until they all
died it was just so much exposition and
baby fetuses like
no no
it was like i will say this russell
crowe gives great vo
not gonna pretend that he doesn't his vo
is fire in that moment it was one of the
biggest regrets i have from the failed
dark universe that we had with tom
cruise was that
dr jekyll that
that russell crowe is because if you
look at his filmography he is both he is
the weird guy for virtuosity and he is
cinderella man he is you know a
beautiful mind literally the reason why
he won the oscar is the duality of that
the guilelessness of him as a
mathematician to like the dangerousness
of him as he starts to go insane anyway
i think the end moment where he snaps
dog neck i i got all of the stuff that
zack snyder was trying to allude to it
is very
shakespearean you know you kill the
detractor and all of that
i would just say that zack snyder has
the visual ambitions
to back he has the visual
effort to back up his aspirations
he does not sometimes take the same care
with dialogue
continuity and plotting
so visually he can communicate so much
with score and sound and images and
really i think sort of drive home
these incredible
conflicts within these characters
but then he writes things that i'm like
son you know what i mean like the words
do matter
and i'm not sure
if the same care has been given to that
for saying less for saying and showing
less
to illustrate more that's what it is
you bring up because john if if we talk
about zack snyder and and goyer helping
writers
no one producing where in in your eyes
does this movie succeed because of them
what is it about zack snyder that made
this movie an elevated treatise on
superman that you responded to so well i
think if you're the son of immigrants if
you're um an immigrant to this country
in any way shape or form
this is the superman for you his entire
experience
and that's why i connect to it so
viscerally as the son of immigrants his
entire experience can be completely
connected to the stuff that immigrants
go through in this country the stuff
that to feeling out of place to feel
like you have something that someone
else doesn't have that makes you
different and how to embrace that when
you've been made fun of for your accent
made fun of for where you came from you
hear the jokes
thrown in as an aside in the
conversation all these things you see as
he progresses through the situation and
you also understand how uh why mom paul
kent are so scared to have the
government find this guy or to have
anybody find out about this guy because
they could look they could actually
imprison him test him check him or
anything else and we've seen that happen
with people coming over to this country
they get vilified by political parties
for their own purposes and so why would
an alien from another planet suffer the
same fate so throughout when people are
like oh it's not hopeful it's not
hopeful it's real and this is you wanted
a real batman and you got nolan's real
batman why are you so adverse to a real
superman and what he's going through as
an illegal alien in every sense of the
word to this country you know there were
no papers it wasn't like he didn't go
through the system he landed on this
planet and so he's got to figure it out
and i think that really connects to me
as we go along and he's got this power
that he does not want to use right and
he has those moments when the bullies
are coming after him and he's there
against the fence you see when he moves
off the fence after he hasn't struck
that kid how he's crunched the uh the
fence post there because he wants to and
even that controversial moment where
it's deciding between saving the
children in the bus or not saving the
children the bus the conversation he has
with his father i know a lot of people
get upset about that but jonathan kent
is scared that his son is going to get
found out and it's a natural honest
scare that you can believe and and i
think that's where some people have an
issue with this film is that it's too
realistic versus aspirational which i
absolutely understand you want your
superman the way you want your superman
but i think him telling the story here
through the prism of an illegal
immigrant or an immigrant to this
country i think is a is why it works for
me so well and what i think boyer and
zack snyder got so well in this movie
you won't get an argument from me
with really any of the stuff that takes
place in smallville just because i
thought it was so well done i i could
clearly
connect with that emotional core i guess
of of you know kent wanting to keep this
a secret but also acknowledging that his
son does have a good heart and he's
gonna want to use his powers for good
even though you know you you may not
want to reveal what your actual
abilities are because there's a lot of
people that are going to be very
interested in doing a lot of those et
experiments on you and so kevin costner
diane lane maybe the biggest two
highlights of the movie for me i wasn't
as enthused jacqueline with the
superman lois lane relationship i didn't
get as much out of that as as i was
hoping for and i thought amy adams is
terrific i like that this is like a a
more intrepid badass i'm not messing
around i'm going to ask the tough
questions kind of lois lane but maybe
did that stifle the relationship i guess
that we were expecting maybe because
we're coming off of margot kidder and
kate bosworth as the character on the
big screen don't disagree with you on
that but also
i would say
that although
i believe amy
and henry have chemistry together it is
not the chemistry
that you need there's an animation of um
superman where lois dies and i forget
which one it is i want to say
it's one of the it's one of the justice
league darks i think
when lois dies and somebody killed her
whatever
doesn't matter
in that animation the two animated
characters every time they were on
screen i was like oh yeah these two and
they were animated and you never felt
that with them that's why like
in the sequel when we have like bathtub
moment there's this is bathtub this one
or the next one bathtub is the next one
right right bathtub is batman v superman
that's right the next one sorry i was
like getting a little bit confused in my
head but i was like that wasn't this one
also because there's an extended cut of
that one which makes it even crazy even
crazier but anyway the water got cold by
the end of that cup yeah it never works
it doesn't work when you think about
them being sexual it works when you
think about them bantering like they are
across the table in that moment that's
where their chemistry lies but the
minute you try to make them a couple
where you're like these two want to rip
each other's clothes off very you know
elizabeth and darcy and pride and
prejudice like there's a tension and a
flirtation between them
that tension and flirtation is missing
so they do have chemistry but the
tension and flirtation of like oh he's
behind a mask and maybe she's behind one
too and once they rip off their mask
they're going to have a great moment
together
it's missing
john how do i ask this judiciously is is
this because you are operating off the
premise that look we're experiencing
superman as he is learning about earth
so he's learning about uh
how how mankind works he's learning
about the way that our planet is
structured the powers that be but he's
also learning about relationships so are
you gonna say that this is kind of like
he is the seventh grader trying to date
the the senior the high school senior
where she just knows so much more about
not just the world that she lives on but
also
relationships and having these feelings
and and processing all of that stuff in
a healthy way is that why maybe the
relationship didn't blossom as much as
we had seen previously
no i think that's an excellent point and
jackie makes excellent points here this
is one criticism that i do agree with
which is what keeps it from being a full
a movie for me is i think amy adams is
good as lois lane i think henry cavill
is great as superman but i agree that
you don't sense that chemistry between
them and i and i wish we'd gotten the
seventh grader fumbling around being
clumsy and awkward he's way too
confident in this situation in a way
that he's not when he dons superman
costume and fights zod he's way more
real it's more of a smirky kind of hay
or you know that kind of thing and it
feels a little weird whereas the
christopher reeve is so endearing that
version with margo kidder because he's
awkward he really does care about her
and she is discovering her feelings for
him and doesn't know how to navigate
that because she's a woman of steel to
have all of a sudden a little softness
come in it's kind of unsettling for her
a little bit so you go along and it's so
believable they go on the flight that's
great we don't get this from this is
more of a
i wouldn't say loveless but there's a
passionless uh connection between them
uh when you see the movie and i think
again amy adams is great as lois lane
and i think as it progresses it gets
better because zack snyder's justice
league that moment where he comes back
to life and they have that moment in the
field that really works so i don't know
how it worked in that version of it but
it didn't quite 100 get there here and
yes you can say oh they just made it's
kind it's kind of new but because it's
new there should be a little bit more of
those scenes where he's kind of clumsy
or awkward or and she's the same way so
that they stumble into it and it would
have been a great way to humanize him in
a way that we would have connected even
more and appreciated what henry cavill
was doing with the role because margo
kitter is great in superman but because
of her performance and all of that but
it's also because we see superman
through her eyes and that lets us care
about him even more and that's missing
here in this movie um unfortunately if
if i'm lois's friend in this movie i am
telling her run from the hills because
look if this guy
is just now getting used to how humans
work and he's sort of a babe in the
woods when it comes to relationship
maybe in the bedroom this is an alien
with untold power i don't want to be the
first human that he has
bedroom fun time with because i don't
know if i'm surviving is that fair to
say that we just do not know what this
man is capable of in the bedroom and i
do not want to be the guinea pig
now you're talking my super
ex-girlfriend now you're talking like
honestly there's a there's a seinfeld
bit about superman not being inherently
good at comedy
i think there might be similar aspects
to this
and i don't want to extrapolate this too
deep because we're trying to keep our g
rating on the podcast suite but listen
i don't know if it's sort of like i
don't know if the flash is a good way
either because i feel like you don't
have to work that hard it doesn't make
you better
um yeah but i mean the flash can be fast
when he wants to um i i just but he
doesn't have to be i just don't know
what like we can we can all admit the
worst superhero you could possibly lay
with in the biblical sense would be the
incredible hulk because that heart rate
gets up there and and then the next
thing you know you're toast but i would
say hulk i would say she-hulk i would
worry because with the incredible hulk
although both are as bad
you might still have all of your
appendages out like the woman could just
like hop off and run like whereas in
with a dude she might clamp down and
that's the end of that and she's a
lawyer so i i don't want to get on the
uh
seriously we're going to get on the
wrong side of that um
producing lucy chimes in wondering about
kryptonians and and if they
make their love in the same way that
humans do i don't think they lay eggs
you know i i think that they're um i
think that they're pretty much the same
way as us but that's neither here nor
there maybe somebody can explain that in
a production down the street in van nuys
are we past the point of no return here
jacqueline and because you're more
negative on this movie than jonas i want
to get your take first
do we bother making another man of steel
movie with henry cavill or do you think
that we just blow this thing up
completely and we just figure out a new
way to do superman for whatever the
future is going to be we got a new
aquaman movie coming out the first one
did over a billion dollars it seems like
wonder woman even though 1984 wasn't
that great still has a chance to
continue on being a leader in this
universe what do we do with supes i i
don't think that this is what warner
brothers will do because i think um
that's just not their way that's not the
way most studios anyway to be so i would
say
talent driven in this respect but i
think we should ask henry cavill what he
wants to do like in all honesty he's
earned the right i think if he wants to
continue playing the character and he
feels that there's a story that he wants
to continue to tell within this universe
he should be given that opportunity that
being said i think he's really happy
doing the witcher
he has reached
a similar level of fame doing that as he
did for superman and we're getting to
the point now where he might be able to
put that to bed and not feel like it
diminished him does that make sense and
and if that does happen i kind of think
he should like if he's able to put
superman to bed and and put tights to
bed and not have it do anything negative
to him and the fact that he's in a
globally recognized tv show that
everybody loves and he's continuing to
do good work
you know what i'd rather you know it's
even less likely to happen but i'd
rather get a man from uncle sequel
before i would say let's do another
superman movie uh i think tom holland
shows that if you take care to cast the
right character you find the right story
doesn't matter how quick it is i i think
a few years ago john it seemed like
henry cavill was dying to get back to
playing superman one more time yeah and
and now i kind of look at him and his
career with superman kind of like steph
curry with his career at the warriors
where if he can win another championship
great he'd love to it's not going to be
necessary for his resume or for his
personal satisfaction anymore like he's
not going to walk around sad and moping
the rest of his life because he never
got to play superman again having said
that i still think he wants to john will
we see henry cavill back as the man of
steel look i said years ago we weren't
going to see affleck back and i and i
was almost right until they did the
flashpoint situation so i'm excited to
see him don and cape again see what
that's all about but i do believe
that it would take an incredible miracle
for him to come back as superman i do
believe warner brothers wants to move on
from the zack snyder verse as strongly
as possible their inability to promote
his blu-ray release of zack snyder just
league speaks volumes they have another
avenue they want and look they're
walking it well you can't argue that
they're making mistakes here i love that
they're becoming more diverse this is
where they want to explore and i think
they want to go with a younger superman
i think they want to start this all over
again and maybe they'll keep obviously
gal gadot they'll keep um
ezra miller they'll keep jason momoa but
i think they're going to move on to
another place here and find another
superman that fits and opening up
multiverse means you can bring in
another superman so to me i think that's
what they're eventually going to do
cabell has made it very clear that he
wants to come back he's taking little
instagram photos with himself next to
the cape i think last year he did one of
those so he knows people want him back
and he was very supportive of zack
snyder's just league coming out so he's
very proud of what he did with this i
don't think he's uh
negan feels negatively about this at all
and he's made it very clear numerous
interviews that he doesn't and that he
loved playing superman so
if they were to bring him back i think
now what jackie points out is excellent
he's moved on from the character and
established his own success so for me i
think cabell has a stronger negotiating
place to be at now if he was to come
back the script's got to really work the
characters have to really work and it
has to make sense for him to don the
capes and cape again and take the abuse
that he's going to take because remember
how people remember he remember went
after him over that mustache thing that
wasn't even his fault on on that justice
that just sweden justice league thing so
it's it's a tough character to embody
because people are going to judge it
harshly i say it's harder to cast
superman than it is batman that's my
honest belief that it's harder to cast
superman than is batman because people's
expectations are sky high for superman
and you don't have a mask to hide behind
and i think there's the difference on so
many levels i i still wish that we got
uh as as great as christopher reeve is
if i could get to my alternate universe
of seeing like a different casting
decision in the history of cinema i
might take christopher walken as
superman because he he was a finalist
back in 78 christopher watkin could have
been our very first big screen superman
yeah i'll also give a shout out to i i
can fly
and i'll give a shout out to uh dean
cain and tom wellington and everybody
else who played george reeves who played
superman on the small screen did you
know john that you compared the
destruction of metropolis like a little
bit spill over into gotham just a bit uh
in man of steel with the battle for new
york and avengers
it's been estimated that the battle
between superman and zod the bulk of
which took place in downtown metropolis
costs
anywhere between 700 billion to 2
trillion
wow worth of damage which is roughly
five times how much the battle of new
york would have cost so
you don't want to ask michael keaton's
vulture about what the emotional cost of
that battle was but as far as just pure
dollars that it's going to cost the city
to repair all this 2 trillion is your
cap for when zod visited so i it i do
think that in retrospect very very wise
decision on clark slash soup slash
cowell's part to go ahead and snap zod
snack um where does this movie rank for
you as we as we say uh good night here
on movie talk before we get to a very
good mail bag from philip calderon today
jacqueline you first where does this
movie rank for you in the dcu and by me
asking that i really just want to know
what's your favorite dcu movie because
it doesn't sound like it's this one
it's definitely bottom tier i think i
would say that my favorite
dceu movie
it might be aquaman
did over a billion dollars worth of
business jon's not happy i really
enjoyed watching aquaman i was not bored
it's not a good movie but i had fun with
it and so i enjoyed it i also enjoyed
wonder woman
not as much as others
i would take wonder woman probably as my
top
and i really liked the batman the new
one so those are my top three i think
and everything else is very very far
down
all right john you uh yeah i'll put
joker getting beat up by those wall
street ruffians in in this as well where
is man of steel for you in your rating
of really any dc movie that's come out
since 2013. uh it's number one
number one for me absolutely man of
steel batman is still too new i've seen
it three times now the batman but it's
still a little new before where i want
to put it um and it's a little unfair to
compare because it's a completely
different world that they're creating
there but uh i would definitely say it's
a man of steel number one um uh
i don't want to do this but it's my own
personal list zack snyder's just like
number two and then wonder woman number
three it was one two wonder woman there
too and the only reason is because zac
the man of steel just appeals to me and
speaks to me in so many ways as a man to
be honest it's a gender thing as a man i
find a lot to connect to especially as i
get older with a number of the
characters and man of steel and one but
wonder woman is an excellent excellent
film there are just a couple of moments
that i don't find as inspirational as
other people do but overall it's a great
film and then zack snyder's just league
i just think what he was able to
accomplish in those four hours is
incredible which is why i moved it up to
number two now but yeah that's my one
two three aquaman is so maneuver
swimming near the bottom to be honest it
was it was i mean i got in so much
trouble for that but i tweeted out that
it's a paint by numbers movie and it's a
disappointment from james wan but i
meant it and every time i've watched it
since it's ridiculous i mean hera he
should have uh was america yes whatever
her name is she she's the one that
should have absolutely been leaning
atlantis she leaves the dope around for
the whole two and a half hours before he
finally figures out he should do
something so to me i have a problem with
that movie because hey we got to see
dolph lundgren as a merfolk
case closed but i'm going to give it
wonder woman is my top but if you ask me
hey mark i can give you a zack snyder
sequel to man of steel i'm going to say
i'll take it right after he gives me the
deserved sequel to the owls of gehul
movie that's the movie that deserves a
sequel that deserves a franchise talking
owls in action are you kidding me it's
my favorite zack snyder movie at least
it was until i found out that he also
directed the music video for seoul
asylum's somebody to shove way back in
the early 90s that was zack snyder
directing it i remembered it was an mtv
buzz clip i saw soul asylum live great
band great video thank you mr snyder and
thank you john roca we're going to hear
a little more from you in just a sec but
right now let's cue the music for
mailbag
[Music]
and as promised our esteemed member of
the ketchup crew today is philip
calderon says my name is philip calderon
one of the movies that i adored so much
during my early teenage years has been
the hobbit trilogy the reason why i
think we need to have a conversation
about the hobbit trilogy is because of
the different reactions from the middle
earth fandom of the love and hate to the
three movies personal ratings for each
movies would be a 72 percent
certified fresh for an unexpected
journey a 74 certified fresh for the
desolation of smaug and 65 fresh for the
battle of the five armies think about
this when you get a chance well we
certainly will thank you philip calderon
i think that those movies are begging
they are fodder for a future episode of
rotten tomatoes is wrong be careful all
you folks in duckburg when you're
swimming in your gold coins there may be
a giant dragon sleeping just below the
surface john roca thank you so much for
joining us here today you're always a
friend of the show
don't be a stranger here and let us know
i know you have so much content that you
have right now with your new setup you
got a new uh face serum that looks like
it's working wonders for you so
what what are all the shows you're
working on give us a couple of it where
can everybody out there find you well
you can always find me at the roca says
on twitter instagram and tick tock the
outlaw nation on twitch i'm doing more
more stuff on twitch so come and find me
there and then my outlaw nation outlet
is youtube.com
john roca says so much happening there
reviews trailer reactions and live shows
uh and also my podcast the top 10 the
cinephiles and geek buddies talk about
film entertainment all that kind of
stuff and thank you guys again for
having me on because i love this movie
and i do love zack snyder and people try
to lump him in that group with michael
baine he does not belong in that group
with michael bay this guy is a more
sensitive nuanced vulnerable filmmaker
than people give him credit for uh and
uh it says something that no one
complains about working with zack snyder
no one and this is that speaks volumes
about how good he runs his set how much
he respects his female actresses how
much he respects people of color how
much he respects the things that he's
trying to create and make uh in this
world and i think he's unfairly vilified
by some critics who see him as a bro
director and he's anything but so i just
want to there's uh there's a few other
directors not uh not not quite uh have
the reputation that he does will say in
the dc eu so um now you all got me
excited for season three of the boys i
cannot wait for that to come out too hey
folks everybody listening we still need
your emails from for hook we want to do
a hook episode we've gotten some great
ones um
one fan dan brockway said that hook it's
quite possibly spielberg's greatest film
wow all right y'all sent us your hot
takes
take there dan i don't know that's gonna
work out that is a bold take sir give us
a quote give us audio whatever you want
email us at rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com
you can also send your mailbags there rt
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com all that
good stuff that you do to your favorite
podcast subscribe rate review share with
your friends feel free to do that with
rotten tomatoes is wrong we certainly
appreciate it next week jacqueline big
big episode because we're not just
talking about one movie no we're talking
about a filmography of
yes
i want you to know
it's in a cage
that's like the worst nick cage
impression but it's the best that i can
give and he'll be okay with that because
he is a magical man that forgives all
yeah well he's a beatles super freak but
he still needs a gun all right thank you
all so much
to john roach our special guest
jacqueline coley producee
uh christian rival caba and brian perez
both helping us out behind the scenes
here the whole family at rotten tomatoes
to you and yours i am mark l is signing
off and saying that the s stands for
hope because kryptonians do not win
spelling bees
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you